let's walk faster I only have 30 minutes
okay I'm gonna take the elevator because
uh just to show you extra amenities nice
yeah so this is my elevator at my
personal elevator in the cloud house
yeah welcome to my room crap there's
people up the artichoke lamps but um so
this is the gym so as you can see if you
go into CS uh-huh
this is what you can get I do I know
right right next door yeah it's
incredibly loud so I'm gonna go here
this might sound a little bit racist but
because you guys are Korean you guys
probably do some kpop dance uh-huh like
this mirror is really cool r.fp can do
you're like is my personal gym I don't
know why there are people inside my gem
I think I'm out soon we have a lot of
artwork so that's really nice too
beautiful and this time we're gonna take
the stairs for exercise spiral staircase
yeah but no you're a pirate I sometime
yeah let's go somewhere else
a cool thing about this place is you
could also rent these bikes so uh and
you can't like pretty much go anywhere
but you just have to bring them back and
free yeah before we continue I just want
to say that this video is sponsored by
its Skillshare now they have a great
promo going on if you could sign up
using the link on the description
because they will give you two months of
premium for free Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills explore classes
in everything from film and video
freelance and entrepreneurship web
development and more premium membership
gives you unlimited access to
high-quality classes from experts
working their fields to help you gain
new skills and live your best life skill
share is super affordable with an annual
subscription of less than ten dollars so
I took a couple of classes and I was
pleasantly surprised by one of their
classes the class is called presentation
essentials how to share ideas that
inspire action by simon Sinek
in case you don't know simon Sinek he is
an author and a motivational speaker the
first time I heard about him is
from a viral video where he talks about
Millennials in the workplace
I thought he was a great storyteller and
for me I think storytelling is an
extremely important skill to have this
class is short sweet and to the point
and I highly recommend checking it out
anyways the first 500 people to click on
the link in the description will get two
months of premium membership for free
and then you could take any classes you
want so check it out oh and then the
next thing we're gonna see is this
harbour market and there's a vending
machine where you can order food mmm
it's pretty funny because sometimes it
screws up like if you buy the Vietnamese
sandwich
so do you wanna you want to learn how to
make more money with your YouTube
channel yes or do you want to learn how
to grow your channel cuz you know I'm
your guy for that by your guy I mean the
guy who is like losing viewers every day
have you watched the startup series I
have my watch episode I think all of
them probably all down yeah oh say I
lied and you back in the day and I
didn't get a response
oh yeah I remember that how's that
you're [ __ ] this kid and then when
you got big on my show I think I need
him wait so you watch a star up series
mm-hmm back then also yeah I watched it
when you were how did you discover on
their eyes I don't know I think I'm not
entirely sure cuz cuz you're all wait oh
no I didn't watch it as you were posting
I don't think oh yeah yeah I think it
was right after you finished startup
series and then I was I went back and
watched all see you so like why cuz
they're trying to text so I don't get
why you watch
oh the startup series or just in general
well sorry series is just ah yeah yeah
yeah Susan you know there are so many
people that still think it's real yeah
they're like it's like why don't like
nog lime yeah you just continue you're
not vine startup like why do you have to
get another job I'm like interested in
tech a little bit yeah nas is fresher in
college with explorers have you ever
taken a CS class in high school yeah in
high school and how was that it was okay
when I didn't really have like what did
they teach you they taught us Java I've
tried to I try doesn't like spent one
month more like a few weeks name like
Swift or like icon but
is that after studied in four years he
had a really really easy job oh my god
shitty filmmaker so as I was saying yeah
yeah yes I did your microphone as a CS
major you know you can come out a
software engineering degree making like
150 to 200 K right off college and then
you can afford this place so think twice
before you start your business major
okay and you to argue this video is
experimental
yeah what's looks the most time when you
make videos or something love for me
used to be planning because I used to
script my videos
oh really yes honey but not anymore not
anymore at all it's it's completely
editing yeah I'm something out so I just
add every single video so what's the
best-case scenario with your YouTube
channel would you like to change content
direction this is I love to do like I'd
love to do more creator self with
videography one day just like very much
just like you know like travel videos
except for my daily life oh yes with the
cinematography with the narrative I
think a lot of travel videos are all
effects and not enough narrative oh okay
straight oh lucky again those are both
unintentional job
[Music]
might be here might be here while
nice she actually really good I could
tell
that's very cool yes jump shot jump shot
it this yeah try not to hit the camera
anyways oh-ho this is this is Rp now and
I'm gonna show him a tour oh I didn't
know you guys would dress up i'm
literally my pajamas but it's fine
yeah actually thumbs up for this well
he's not dressed up he always wears this
well that it looks good though like it
yeah okay it's it's her brand I guess so
her outfits are my branding
anyways so this is the living room you
know I bought a new projector it's
probably gonna take a while to turn on
so I'm not gonna turn on but anyways you
could come here and film this where do
you know what this is is it a wireless
phone charger it's a very expensive
coaster but yeah hmm Wow
you know I always wondered what would
happen if I uh if I charge my phone it's
gonna blow up or maybe it it goes to 100
percent faster hey I need a project
you're so big well I didn't know it was
gonna be that big I thought it was gonna
be this size but yeah so I bought like
the most expensive one as an inch and I
work intact okay okay and because I work
in tag I'm able to afford this oh [ __ ]
yes some SNES that's cute
so but yeah if you didn't enjoy CS for
your first class it doesn't matter
because if you grind for a little bit
not your separate life okay I don't know
if money is important to you but for me
it's important to feel you know free so
you can buy a big s forget today I'm
just like financial freedom you're like
oh man Palo Alto restaurants are so
expensive yeah I don't even think about
the bill and I just I just eat whatever
I want y'all look at this sick ass video
Oh who's this a youtuber y'all know he
looks trash wait how my good friend she
crazy I hate watching myself me too oh
man I can't wait let's watch your
channel wait no no
and an RP okay your channels kind of
hard to find Eliot
Choi okay there we go Eliot 25 Eliot
Troy Eliot Harvard oh man look at these
thumbnails man they're so high quality
so did you know that if you if you made
a Harvard video it would blow up even
though that you don't go to Harvard
yeah makes sense are there any youtubers
you guys don't like you mean just like
in general yeah um I might make a [ __ ]
just one guy who lives in like Mountain
View mm-hmm yeah she's kind of a
arrogant rich prick after oh that's the
guy I see guys crazy this is not about
to do it no it's City Oh same difference
yeah yeah [ __ ] did why do you always
wear adidas I'm so comfortable do you
have any other campus no I just have but
they're pretty though I you should have
some oh yeah let me show you might be
this mess okay so I bought these first
for myself and then when I watched a 1
million studio they all had it
wow they [ __ ] copied me man yeah
clearly oh yeah yes all right let's go
back and pretend you didn't see my room
all right let me show you my dope ass
room and what you can get if you have a
sick mass salary okay
all right first you got my sick huh oh
why do you even need it that's just like
excessive at that point yeah I think for
pornography is really good because what
they don't even make that aspect ratio
in porn I mean yeah I know but but it's
not about watching one video for me at
least I think I'm a lot different oh I
got it one two tasks right right so what
I do is I have like yeah and then
another cool thing that you can do is it
can act as two different liners and this
is actually impressive
for example now this monitor is attached
to my computer while this one is
attached to so crazy thought what if you
had two monitors
hmm with yet two monitors and double the
price why would I pay twice for honor
yeah but then again it's like this is
like 16 double the price
yeah wipe the question I had to modulate
oh yeah what if I do want something in
between whatever I'm just rich bro okay
that's that's something here here you
know where I could wirelessly charge my
phone
Shepard's my form okay let's pretend
this is my phone so it's slightly better
because back then I would have to plug
my phone in right uh-huh
and when I wake up I'd have to detach it
uh-huh
which requires an extra step but now
when I wake up I'm just like this that's
that's crazy deep boom yeah and also I
want to try I was really hoping for this
one thing I'll tell you what it is I was
hoping that this would work because this
is like a wireless charging all it's
doing it's doing something yeah it's
freaking out look Oh what you're
supposed to do
this is actually an annoying you're
supposed to charge Oh like this and then
there's wireless charging uh-huh yeah so
I thought it would be the same kind of
Larnaca it's not okay so I should DC us
to get to get wired Shah Mardan
everywhere more efficient toothbrush and
marginally oh I didn't even see that now
you got me into like like it spits out
elastic you're closer to the to the head
look see see oh my god like it was like
just another e alright
also Sensodyne it's the most expensive
kitchen yeah so pretty quick and then
sarathi you use that too right I do yeah
good [ __ ] what also have this impressive
here I used to have an iPad here and I
would watch kpop while I brush my teeth
as well but I've outgrown that now you
have like a TV inside of your mirrors
anything ya know be sick but not on oh
my god Elliott oh it's still sick I like
this youtuber yeah I don't know about
that you see modest and nice cuz like I
know Elliott likes gear and
yeah here I got a microphone it's why I
do my blog I pull it here and I talk and
then I put my camera here and then I
connect this to the camera so that I
could see what I look like
pretty cool right what's your setup like
probably not as cool as my iPhone on the
tripod listen the time all I did you
have an iPhone that's not bad what are
you a phone Elliot
let's say okay and then oh yeah our paws
you guys I'm a possum no I don't did
apparently it's purge NZ like this is
like a rich show I guess I can't be in
the upper class you know I don't know if
I can be hit bad yeah but yeah I mean I
bought it when it first came out so are
the second ones coming soon
no they already are you don't have them
I thought you would yeah I know I
thought I thought you were in tech yeah
I know but okay I know I'm gonna hit up
I'm gonna buy them oh yeah the second
ones are pretty good because they're
Wireless sure but mine or not yeah Apple
watch see this is one thing I've never
understood what what is it for yeah
absolutely nothing it's actually just to
tell people you're rich and right but
mine is trash because the red thought is
not there okay but people still know
you're rich no okay well we'll only if I
hide if I hide it well because this is
actually generation 3 not generation 4
generation 4 is the latest version this
is all going right over my head I don't
know anyways how do you think these
notes cost 12 bucks each
I think it's like 30 bucks each let me
use my extremely comb on or to check it
out but like why why though cuz I'm rich
man 50 bucks 35 bucks and I'm not sure
this one I think this was a Kiwi if you
just didn't buy all of these uh-huh how
much richer would have been you'd be
$150 with you you you could probably
save us for the next ear plugs the
single forever
okay okay right right you're rich I'm
sorry I just you don't take into my
savings account okay okay what else what
else well how much you think these costs
that looks like to [ __ ] you buy a
Walmart yeah that's a cue for you it's
actually pretty cheap trash but then
this is actually legit it's a real
painter like if you look closely it's
paint you know I like this try isn't it
why don't you put this next to monitor
you can afford things to look at yo le o
le you like yours Marky what where's
your listen this is fun oh wait have you
guys heard of these his old school
yeah they flop so what I want you I
waited eight hours just to buy these
useless piece of [ __ ] what did they do
like Google glass but no no it's like
snapchat and then basically what you can
do is you can record like 10 seconds
with it and then send it as a snap
pretty cool right yeah yeah look at look
at this I have a mouse and a trackpad
but why redundancy if you if you learned
about CS you would know we're we're done
and C is all about
imagine you have a hard drive and you
have all your files there what happens
if your hard drives die you lose our
files right so redundancy is about
copying those files into different you
know different hard drives right so that
if you lose one you're not gonna lose
all of it right so uh but but why to for
redundant and like imagine if like I'm
like oh man my mouse doesn't work
anymore [ __ ] and then if you bought an
expensive Mouse shouldn't it work but
it's not it's not that expensive I have
a cheap Mouse not because I'm poor it's
because I actually like cheap Mouse's
see that's what poor people say mmm can
you do this
who's your mouse all these yeah we all
have trackpads on a laptop yeah I know
but what if I'm using my desktop setup
I'm sure I could configure some sort of
shortcut yeah you could actually you
guys here just press like this or
something yeah yeah but still okay right
and pressed and pressed
yeah yeah just
damn that's crazy dude definitely gonna
study yes all right
my job is done here mm-hmm all right I'm
gonna end the video thanks for watching
he's gonna join CS alright thanks for
watching guys check out Elliott's
channel check out our peas Channel he
needs it yeah he doesn't even have this
silver play button oh yeah
it's coming soon I swear see ya I didn't
have I didn't have as much fun in
college because I was in CS now that
it's off the record yeah